emmanuel is with us and Phoenix Thank
You Manuel how are you I'm good how are
you guys better than I deserve how can
we help you today well first of all I
just want to thank you for your
teachings for your principles I saw you
guys have been smart friends here in
Phoenix and it was awesome thank you
well thank you sir
how can we help today well the reason
for the card actually is more for
advising kids I'm actually young I'm
looking for for an interview in a couple
of days for assistant manager at a bank
and I just want some advice some tips is
actually a really good opportunity for
me and I'm really feeling the
nervousness chicken it's my ride all
right Chris I was actually thinking that
you were gonna tell them everything that
I did all the other good things that I
did when I interviewed here oh no idea
he doesn't remember my interview that's
how that's how great it was Oh
Emmanuel I would say hey listen research
the company make sure you know
everything about it you're passionate
about the company not only at a head
level but also at a heart level that's
the first and foremost and number two
out of all the things you can bring to
the table they want to know that you've
got an intensity about you you'll run
through a brick wall and you will win
they want to know that you're a winner
and then of course just obviously the
competency part you know exactly that
the skill that you're going to be doing
but the skill if you know the skill only
but you don't the intensity to run
through a brick wall and win you having
the skill doesn't matter it just puts
you right there in the in the file with
all the other 300 applicants they wanted
to see something a fire in your eyes
that you will win you will make
something happen and you're gonna make
that vision for the for the for the
banking center come to fruition faster
than it would if you were not part of it
so intensity know something about the
organization from a heart level and
obviously the core competencies one
moment when I'm nervous or when I'm
concentrating my natural state of
affairs is not a smile which what some
people naturally smile when they're
nervous or when they're concentrating
which one are you why
in Ireland I think I do smile but you
know you get that face smile and yeah I
don't want you I don't want to I don't
want you have nervous laughter no one
should have a fake smile but I do want
you to not be looking like you know you
just ate a pickle okay so just smile was
was where I was going just smile but
don't do it in a weird way so as you
said I agree with you on that
yeah then the second thing is this in
addition to what Chris said and Chris
gave you some great advice there and I
would do every one of those things I
always just try to switch shoes with the
interviewer for a minute and walk around
in his or her shoes what are they
looking for and for instance in our
business we're a small business and so
what we're looking for quite honestly is
is this person going to be effective
enough at this job that we make more on
them than they cost us are they looking
to add value to the organization rather
than there to extract something and just
say I'm gonna be here when I come in the
door I'm gonna be an asset I'm gonna be
bringing things I'm gonna cause things
to occur around here that are good
things I'm not here looking to see what
I can take I'm here looking to see how I
can serve and one guy that came to work
here many years ago said I don't care
I'll just set up chairs I'll sweep the
floor but I'm coming in here because
this thing is working and I want to be
part of it and he's just I'll do
anything that's within reason you know
and you don't obviously want to say you
have sweep floors of the bank that'd be
weird but but but you just you know you
see what I'm saying is you're trying to
bring something to them rather than just
looking for how much you pay and how
much of the benefits and how much can I
get out of this place I'm here to be a
parasite no I'm here - I'm here to add
value to the organization and if you'll
show me how to do that then you got the
right guy because I'm going to be doing
that every day while I'm here okay is
that helpful at all yeah it is the thing
is on from what I heard they're
interviewing a lot of people with more
experience than me and that's what's
actually that's where I need to be the
more you know if they got a lot of
experience in banking you probably can
because a lot of experience in banking
could make you sour these days yeah and
you don't need to be sour go in there
smiling and talking about how you can
add value and then I'm gonna bring it as
Chris said I'm gonna be intense I'm
gonna be the guy that runs through a
wall I'm the guy that gets things done
and you know I've got enough experience
and you guys will show me what to do and
you have let me tell you what Trump's
experienced coach ability and if you can
convince them you're coachable that
Trump's experienced somebody sometimes
people are so experienced they they
think they know everything and they
don't they don't have any ability to be
coached to fit into the culture to be
effective and so sometimes not always
but I think you can beat that
you